welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of hawkeye
episode four partners am i right in
which clint barton sips from the cup of
thanos and then goes full thanos by
letting his daughter figure drop from a
ledge i'm gonna go through this episode
scene by scene to break down all the
visual clues and details that you might
have overlooked let's get started the
episode opens precisely on the shot that
episode 3 left off jack decayne holding
the ronin sword to clint's throat stay
exactly where you are despite the oh boy
an avenger energy jack plays the rest of
the scene with let us remember how close
jack actually was to be heading hawkeye
in this moment also eleanor's reaction
to scene and avenger what the hell is
going on
and why is there an avenger in my dining
room yeah eleanor's eyes go so wide he
could drive a trust a bro truck through
him she regains composure but verifica
does a great job selling the pure panic
that her secret criminal conspiracy is
about to be disheveled by an adventures
level threat just as it was in the
opening scene of this series now as
eleanor and jack interrogate them
there's actually a sword dividing the
sides of this table kate and clint are
literally on the chopping block you'll
notice they all have mugs patterned with
bees and hexagonal hives speaking of
hives it's the one-division beekeeper
all over again no no witchcraft here but
i do like the set design choice to try
to force this awkward family unit into a
hive that is run by this queen bee
eleanor says well i guess i'm just gonna
have to trust everyone at this table to
do what's right yeah she's referring to
kate and clint here but jack and herself
are also at this table and it could be a
non-verbal signal to jack to make a move
on his end of this crime organization
maybe leak details about clint's family
to maya lopez clint spots a ronin sword
and as he gets it to leave they cleverly
show the moment he swiped it oh get my
code jack
[Music]
you can actually see kate's eyes dart to
the side past jack right as jack sips
his tee and jack looks back at her and
she lowers her eyes right as you see
clint's reflection move in the glass
behind kate so that was a moment that
clint grabbed the sword as jack was
sipping and focused on kate then eleanor
suddenly threatens clint she's pretty
good at all this but natasha romanov was
pretty damn good at it wasn't she being
good isn't always enough to keep you
alive
i see
clint yeah do you have kids
yeah i'm gonna assume that you do why
would eleanor assume clint had kids
unless she had done a bit of digging on
him the barton family was previously
kept off the books but now that clint
brought them to new york city a broadway
show out for dinner to see the 30 rock
christmas tree which will be the same
place that eleanor will soon host her
bishop christmas party these kids might
be a bit easier for any prying eyes to
track as clint refuses to drop the case
and leaves eleanor makes a call
it's eleanor um
could you call me back please it's
urgent now my initial thought was that
she could be calling uncle but actually
i think eleanor was in touch with val
who did place the hit on clint now we
never knew for sure when that black
widow post credit scene took place but
based on their heavy coats it could have
been taking place around the same time
as these hawkeye episodes are december
2024 and valve's assignment to elena
could have come right after a call from
her friend eleanor if eleanor was in
touch with val it would mean that
eleanor might also know clint was the
ronin and she might join val into that
totally mysterious insight that val has
into what went down on vormir and this
might also suggest that val could also
be in business with uncle kingpin we
think which makes sense for a shadowy
corrupt government figure like her
making side deals with john walker but
it would also make uncle super well
connected with contacts in the us
government now eleanor has this painting
of a figure wearing a floral orange on
black print
snuggy but this does match the suit that
kate swiped from her aunt moira
brandon's closet in episode 2 in the
comics moira brandon was the elderly
actress whose estate in california
hawkeye obtains and repurposes for the
west coast avengers campus so now we got
a shady aunt and a shady uncle after
texting laura to research sloane limited
that's the shell company qazi was listed
working for on eleanor's computer laura
calls him back in the next scene track
suits so sloane's uh front
yep
he said that his boss jack ducane never
gives him a day off jack's ceo
he's laundering money for the big guy
confirming a few things first that jax
naivete is totally an act he actually is
running the tracksuits and laundering
money for a big guy aka uncle and who's
bigger than wilson visk but
interestingly this also tells us that
laura barton has resources of her own
enough to flip a tracksuit to spill the
beans about his boss secret information
that eleanor and jack are definitely
hiding from kate but information that
laura was able to get in just a few
minutes from her kitchen in missouri
laura further stokes this intrigue
linda you mean the rolex
you know
no thanks i don't think so
why was that destroyed like years ago
well i thought so but i thought the same
thing about your fancy outfit yeah laura
switches to german so her kids won't
understand but remember laura was also
plugged into clint's tactics and his
history with the tracksuits all the way
back in episode two and considering how
chill she was that clint has this
mission he's gotta do she was always
okay with clint's partnership with
natasha laura is a professional she has
a history i think laura could be
revealed as an ex-shield agent like
mockingbird who is hawkeye's love
interest in the comics a title that
laura maybe used to have before retiring
in a title that she might have passed
down to another like the character of
bobby morse remember when we first met
laura barton in the mcu in age of ultron
tony stark did quip this is an agent of
some kind but i have some other thoughts
about laura barton and a relationship
with that rolex later as kate chats with
eleanor the stocky and singing from the
mantle are two white ones and one dark
one now you would think that the dark
one would be for the mysterious
interloper jack but i actually think
that one could represent eleanor truly
the most machiavellian of this trio kate
doesn't think her mom dances but a
surprise eleanor is more mobile than we
think but still soulless as
yes dancing multi-millionaires secretive
crime lords so endearing then they make
fun of jack from misquoting ferris
bueller and forrest gump life moves
pretty fast you never know what you're
gonna get
clint isis's bruises and kate cheers him
up with a handful of christmas movie
dvds including the santa claus the 1964
rudolph the red-nosed reindeer tv
special the polar express christmas
vacation die hard that's the christmasy
action comedy that this whole hawkeye
series is trying to tonally replicate
clint sips from a purple thanos was
right mug after clint seemed to actually
consider this idea in episode 1 upon
reading it on the urinal he now seems to
just be embracing the cynicism they
listened to a cover of mele kalikimaka
the bing crosby version of which was
famously featured in christmas vacation
kate uses one of aunt maura's movie
posters as a whiteboard a chance of love
presumably some old romantic comedy
actually her outfit is kind of
christmassy maybe something like white
christmas notice how kate drew glasses
on morris face kate asks clint about
more trick arrows how do we get more
trick arrows well there are no more
trick arrows
like in the world
basically have a few more trick arrow
heads you can't just put them on any
shaft
huh so i guess clint's aeroshafts are so
uniquely structured that you can't just
buy them in stores so does this mean
clint had to go back through sokovia to
retrieve all the arrows that he fired in
age of ultron or is this a new problem
created without an avengers hq to
mass-produce arrows or did this episode
just need an excuse to split up clinton
kate and bring the larpers back into
things probably that i mean kate really
asks the reasonable question have you
ever heard of boomerang arrows which
clint balks at here because i guess he'd
have to dodge when they would boomerang
back to him but in the comics clint is
all about boomerang arrows precisely for
the reason of making them easier to
retrieve and reuse clint brags about
being able to knock someone out by
flicking a coin at them which he shows
kate how to do this is a move he learns
from his brother in the comics who also
uses the words that a dime would be too
small in a move that we have seen in
these episodes credit sequences each
episode clint explains that his best
shot was the one he never took referring
to natasha i was sent to take her out
and when i got there
when it was time i just
had this feeling that you wanted out
turns out i was right telling us more of
their famous encounter in budapest but
now from clint's perspective this sets
up the similar moment between kate and
elena bulova in the final minutes of the
episode when kate had the shot yelena
silently shakes her head and kate
remembers what clint told her in this
moment and lowers her arrow this hawkeye
found her black widow i mean it's
usually not the case but i gotta say
nothing is more of a christmas miracle
than getting a theory right it's a great
feeling it's kind of like when you're
doing that holiday shopping and you get
a great deal like you know what's better
than buying stuff you want getting that
same brand new stuff for 90 off and
that's what you can get with dealdash
one of the leading auction sites in the
united states deal dash has been in
business for over a decade and hosts
hundreds of auctions daily they auction
brand new items ranging from tvs and
laptops to tools and kitchenware all
with guaranteed free shipping they even
occasionally sell cars all auctions
start at zero dollars and you can have a
90-day money-back guarantee on the first
bid pack purchase you can use deal dash
both on the website dealdash.com and
through their ios and android apps the
mechanics are simple all auctions start
at zero dollars each bid raises the
final auction price by one cent and
resets the clocks at 10 seconds after
the 10 seconds run out the final bidder
wins and can claim the auction win by
paying the final price you can always
buy your desired item for the listed
price get all your bids back and then
use them on another auction so use the
promo code newrockstars dealdash.com new
rockstars for an additional 100 free
bids when making your first bid pack
purchase don't wait start that bidding
today meanwhile clint watches the final
scene in its wonderful life when george
finally gets his family back after
living in a reality where they were
erased from existence clint remembering
when he went through that with his
family during the blip and kate deduces
that clint was the ronin and clint
monologues about his function as a
killer i was a weapon aimed by the right
people the right targets so he's
referring to the time when nick fury
would use him as an assassin like when
he almost killed thor and then when he
was controlled by loki in the 2012
avengers now elena is being used the
same way by val as a weapon against
clint and then as he sleeps clint
remembers his target practice with lila
and in-game moments before she dusted
along with the rest of the family but
then also years later after the in-game
final battle when he returned to them
and of course his final moments with
natasha but he also flashes back to this
memory of his ronin days that we haven't
seen before as he kills a few guys in a
van can't tell who they are but klimt
uses his sword one moment to block a
shot seems to sever the barrel of the
gun the next morning kate's shirt is the
same like of the space dog shirt that
kate wears in the comics leica was a
stray dog that the soviets sent into
space in 1957 the first animal to orbit
earth whom the russians tragically never
planned to recover micah didn't survive
the trip it is awful one of two
unforgivable anti-doggo moments this
episode merry christmas clint's trick
arrows conveniently ended up accessible
by the same group of larper cops who
ended up with his ronin suit so k tracks
them down in central park
[Applause]
ice wall look at bobby drake back there
and their superpower doom move looks a
lot like thor's move of slamming his
hammer and releasing lightning bolts
kate meets officer wendy conrad who in
the marvel comics is bombshell a
mercenary who juggles explosives part of
the death rows group fought by hawkeye
and mockingbird later she says her wife
embroidered her bag with the word
bombshell and she does seem oddly okay
to risk her job tampering with and steal
evidence in exchange for costumes
meanwhile another larper's name is
orville maybe orville bach aka oddball
from that same group the death throws i
doubt these larpers will truly be
antagonist to clint but are rather just
nods to these circus weirdos that he
faced in the comics clint chats with
qazi you know what my boss wants
you know what he's already done to get
it
i know he doesn't like his attention
that's for sure another reminder of
uncle's violent track record and his low
profile that could put a wedge between
maya's vengeance against the ronin and
uncle kingpin's priorities clint meets
up with the larpers with grills making
some snickerdoodles there is gamer gear
everywhere you can see the game rise of
the tomb raider and then a playstation
xbox a gamecube old school nes d d
poster these are my kind of nerds now
when they go to the godfrey apartment
there's an initial overhead shot of
clint and kate from their lookout post
that shows the hanging christmas lights
down below for telling how clint will
later allow kate to safely drop into
this sort of net although i'll say she
totally could have fallen straight
through that and broken her neck kate
ignores clint's advice and sneaks in
with an old man taking the elevator upon
entry she sets off the silent alarm she
covers her cameras with those putty
arrows and around maya's apartment is
various artwork that links to her
indigenous heritage is actually artwork
that she drew of herself with her
prosthetic leg you'll also notice
there's a record player on the coffee
table since we know that she enjoys
music by feeling the vibrations and kate
finds the vintage rolex which along with
the transmitter likely contains some
other hidden micro hardware and clint
says as long as someone i used to work
with
they've been out of the game a long time
but their identity still touched that
watch
oh you know the tracksuits find out
about it it would blow their cover
goodbye friend now the straightforward
answer to this watch is that it could
just belong to laura barton and reveal
something about her past as an agent
maybe mockingbird but really in a
post-hydra world where everyone is
muddied with espionage connections what
other level of secret identity would
characters in this world still care to
hide if not
skrulls now i'm not saying that laura
barton or her kids are definitely
themselves scrolls in disguise i mean
they could be that would be sick but
rather like nick fury and maria hill
laura could be a human agent with a past
partnership with the squirrels on earth
perhaps helping them like she has been
doing keep a low profile a rolex isn't
really something i'd imagine laura
barton wearing but it is a kind of
accessory you could see on the wrist of
nick fury nick fury is currently working
undercover with the scrolls and he has a
history with clint and laura when he
visited their home in age of ultron and
he said these words here we all are back
on earth fury is a still alive old
friend that clint would not want to get
in trouble and with nick fury's pager
this guy has a history of hiding gadgets
in plain sight to connect him with
extraterrestrial partners laura barton
could have been part of that secret
operation a covert network that she
could still access from her farmhouse
kitchen i mean i don't know guys it
could be overthinking it i just think
with secret invasion coming soon
everything espionage flavored in the mcu
should give us a whiff of scroll kate
finds maya's notepad listing the names
and ages of the barton family
interesting how she listed the ages of
cooper and lila but not nate but then in
the rooftop brawl across the street
yalane at one point has them at gunpoint
but maya swoops and kicks the gun out of
her hand and then elena hits maya with
some red widows bites so these two are
not on the same team they both want to
hunt clint but for different reasons
elena rolls to her feet doing that
three-point pose that she mocked natasha
for always doing in black widow and then
when kate leans on her bow she bends it
that allows her to control her slide to
kick the gun away very cool move elena
tosses kate over the edge but right
before she does so she hooks a wire to
kate's belt so that kate won't fall to
her death as clint panics reaches down
for her and then decides to cut her
loose notice the music
[Music]
get out of here
this is the same music from clint and
natasha's moment on vermeer and in-game
please no
it's okay
and if you think about it elena hooked
kate to that wire so that she wouldn't
fall the same way natasha hooked clint
to the wire so that he wouldn't fall so
it wasn't just kate seeing something and
elena this black widow spared her life
the way natasha spared clint and then
elena hits clint in the neck with the
widow's bite and reveals herself
[Music]
ah and the music here is lauren boss's
score from the black widow film i should
have come back for you you don't have to
say that it's okay
it was real to me too
and that reminder of his lost natasha
the law set still haunts him forcing him
to keep playing this game of managing
loss leads clint to uphold his promise
to eleanor and tell kate i don't want
you anymore do you understand i'm not
gonna do it do you hear me
do you hear me ah particularly cutting
for clint to use these words considering
their playful banter over not hearing
each other last episode which was the
peak of their partnership but now
hamburg to support our channel check out
one of our great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eevos follow new rockstars and subscribe
to interactive for more analysis of
everything marvel thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you